[Music]  stealing you and your friends are dead  sound right  where did you learn to count Haywired  listening up about 5,000 volts what kind  of thing does that mob bank I guess the  joke was just crazy as they say where's  the alarm gun boss told me when the guy  was done I should take him out one less  share something similar no no  that's a lot of money if this Joker guy  was so smart he too had us bring a  bigger car I'm betting the Joker told  you to kill me as soon as we loaded the  cash no no I killed the bus driver bus  driver what do the rest of the guys just  do the same Tiny's to believe in things  honor respect look at you what do you  believe I believe whatever doesn't kill  you simply makes  stranger  you